I'm ballsy I'm a confident person I
don't take [ __ ] and so I think that
that's been a good thing in terms of
advocating for different film projects
and so all of the films I've made her my
best film and the next one that I'm
working on is also my best film I'm
Kaitlin may bark I am a producer from
Brooklyn New York right now film to me
feels like it's home it's a community
it's most of what I think about most of
the time it's most of my friends it's
most of the birthday parties I go to as
a producer I feel like I'm in a
relationship with everyone else who's
working on the film after nine years
Germantown high school in Philadelphia
is closing for good students from
Germantown high will now go to school
with kids from Martin Luther King
Germantown and MLK our traditional
riding we come from humility we got
mismatched pleats you go to different
schools
difficult situations but that's not what
makes us weak that's what makes us
strong inand everybody else
I've gotten a tattoo for every feature
I've done and I like the idea that
they've changed me and so I want to mark
each one with a physical change it's
about a football team and so I got their
team cheer tattooed on my ankle and a
crown because they're Kings I'm a real
sucker for people communicating their
ideas with passion and for people who
aren't afraid to do something a little
weird and so a lot of the projects that
I've been drawn to are people who are
sort of unabashedly passionate about
intimate relationships and telling sort
of underserved or unheard stories and
being a megaphone for something
the women were most attracted to me
amateur comedians
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
stage the hardest-working country show
business
I predominantly work with women when I
can in film and that's both because I'd
notice that there are fewer women if I
have an opportunity to hire women I will
because I believe in advancing our
careers and sort of calling people up
but also because I just like want less
[ __ ] on set I think one of the
secrets to being successful as a female
producer is to be constantly working to
eliminate female from that description
I'm really excited about the idea that
in the future I will just be a producer
it's my greatest weakness and the most
challenging part of being a producer is
to find the financing every film is
funded and sort of this like very
scrappy individual way it's very DIY
it's like kind of punk rock and you like
move into each of the films being like
how the hell are we gonna do this how
are we gonna do this one my Emmy lives
at my mom's house and she keeps asking
for Emmy to get a boyfriend so it would
be really nice if his name could be
asking
you